this is what the people of Lebanon have
feared a violent turn for what has been
four days a popular mostly peaceful
uprising in the northern town of Badawi
the Lebanese army tried to clear a
blocked road we don't know who fired
first but at least three protesters were
injured it was an isolated incident but
there's clearly an anxiety that it could
happen again roadblocks are a key tactic
of the protesters small sit-ins popping
up around the cities this is the main
Ring Road in Beirut shut for much of the
day by just a few dozen protesters the
police are here but it's been clear
through the week that they don't want a
confrontation this video has gone viral
in just a few hours subtle solidarity
between protester and policeman but on
the ring road there were orders to move
them on and they tried among the group
here being pulled back by an officer was
aid sedan he's an airport worker from
Beirut my back was again who with whom
they were linked is yelling I have no
idea what the religion is of the other
protesters whether they're Sunni Shia
Druze or Christian all I know is that
their pain is my pain this revolution is
a revolution of hunger it's a revolution
of the disadvantaged this revolution
doesn't have religious sects things
quickly calmed down the police tactics
seemed to be to use just enough force
and intimidation to persuade people to
go home
[Applause]
but it's not working this father even
felt comfortable or determined enough to
bring his newborn here it's dream for us
I know as long as the protesters keep up
this carnival atmosphere it's very hard
for the authorities to move them on and
there is another intimidation political
opponents of this people's protest are
here and their confrontational on Friday
the leader of Hezbollah the powerful
political and religious group backed the
government not the protesters this is
the consequence on the street
Paula Yacoubian was elected to
Parliament just a year ago she's an
independent MP and sees herself as a
genuine people's politician it's not
easy when Sayed Hassan Nasrallah goes on
TV and tell them you have to fear this
finger no it's not easy so now I think
our people are very brave they're still
resisting and there will be more to come
even if they crush this revolution it
will come back well there was an
expectation that the intimidation we've
seen from some political causes combined
with some of the tactics used by the
police and army might spook people into
not coming out but the numbers tonight
look as though they're as big as any
that we've seen all week the protesters
say they will in the coming hours join
hands in a human chain stretching the
length of the country there is a
determination to bring this protest back
to its roots a National Secular peaceful
drive to topple the government and to
change Lebanon mark stone Sky News in
Beirut